a party in Buenos Aires to celebrate the
victory of Alberto Fernandez and the
defeat of president Mauricio Macri all
the synturion says she is proud of the
results all my life I have been fighting
for social justice and the past four
years have been torture for me seeing
how the economic situation deteriorated
because of McCree now I can be proud of
being Argentinean again economic
situation with a 55 percent inflation
rate and the possibility of a default in
the foreign debt
Alberto Fernandez was chief of staff to
former president networkers nur his
running mate is two-time President
Cristina Fernandez de Kirchner Alberto
Fernandez went from being a staunch
critic of Cristina Kirchner to joining
forces with her in order to unite the
Pyrenees party to defeat mercury until
December 10th the president is Macri and
of course we will collaborate and
everything we can because the only thing
we care about is that Argentinians stop
suffering when elected in 2015 Mauricio
Macri promised to solve Argentina's
endemic economic problems but his plan
did not work out well as his government
was forced to request an emergency loan
from the IMF and inflation and poverty
increased while in office et cetera I
want to congratulate president-elect
Alberto Fernandez I just talked to him
for the great choice that people have
made I invited him tomorrow to breakfast
because he has to start a transition
period
please this is for Argentina the orderly
transition that brings tranquility to
all Argentines because here the only
important thing is the future and
well-being of Argentines the big
question in Argentina is what's coming
next the question then becomes of the
what next are we going to see any
genomic plan are we going to see a
cabinet and who will be in charge of
that crucial renegotiation with
Argentine creditors the new president
takes office in December but Argentina
needs an urgent plan to stabilize the
economy these people want to believe the
best is yet to come
Teresa whoa al Jazeera bono Cyrus